should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
prices go up all the time because the
government is so involved that's why it
keeps getting more expensive and the
quality goes down the quality of
Education I mean a high school degree
you know 50 years ago is is way more
valuable than a college degree today
even a master's degree the governments
have destroyed the value of degrees
while dramatically increasing the price
to to get one so government drives
quality down and price up the free
market does the reverse government let's
say the post office right post office
was a problem and so then FedEx came
along right and okay we can avoid the
post office or more recently uh
governments create monopolies in taxi
cabs well Uber comes along Lyft comes
along and and creates some competition
to these government monopolies so the
same thing is going to happen with money
government money is is so bad
and it's going to get worse that the
market is going to offer Alternatives
yes the government is going to try to
put up roadblocks to protect its
Monopoly but ultimately it won't work
[Music]
hello everyone
I am speaking today with Peter Schiff
The Economist and stock broker who
successfully predicted the 2008 housing
crisis today we will discuss the current
market hyperinflation
fiat currency and the value of gold in
times of instability
looking forward to the conversation
so thank you very much for talking to me
today and to everyone who's watching and
listening thank you for your time and
attention that's much appreciated so the
first thing I guess I might ask is what
do you think it is that the typical
person who's watching or listening
should know on the financial front
practically for their own protection and
and incremental wisdom that they don't
know I mean people are aren't taught
even the basics of how to think
financially in our education system and
so maybe you could walk through what you
regard as the as the basics of fun of
financial literacy on the Practical
front
uh well there's a lot there but I think
the the most pertinent thing
that people need to understand
before they make any Investments really
particularly now
is inflation
and the impact that inflation is going
to have
on the decisions that they make on their
savings and their investment because
inflation
is probably a bigger threat now
than it's ever been and therefore it's a
even bigger Factor
in determining everything that we do and
ultimately uh what the rewards are going
to be or the returns
from your Investments and and the reason
I think that inflation
is a bigger problem now
then it's it's been in the past is
because of the fiscal predicament that
most of the major governments
have you know put themselves in
and the fact that
all politicians
unfortunately and this is a a fatal flaw
in democracy
is that politicians
first and foremost care about themselves
and their own political career and their
own re-election that's what they do for
a living they are career politicians and
so you know like anybody else
you know they're they're they're you
know concerned about
perpetuating their career and most
people who are in politics they really
enjoy it I mean they they like all the
perks that come with it uh you know you
get a lot of uh you know respect if
you're you know United States or
Congressman you're a senator uh you know
it it's it's a it's a career that a lot
of people would aspire to and once you
get there you know once you get to
Washington and I'm sure this is true and
you know every you know country in
Europe and all around the world that you
know you like it right you like the
lifestyle you like The Prestige that
comes with being a government official
so you want to stay there right well how
do you stay in office well you got to
keep getting elected you know in the
United States you know we get elections
every two years right so
politicians are are very concerned about
you know the polls and they're
constantly got their finger in the air
seeing where the winds are blowing and
they don't want to say anything or do
anything that might jeopardize their
re-election and of course one of the
most important things that you need to
get reelected is you need a lot of money
you need to spend money on advertising
on television which is expensive and so
you tend to cater to donors
um whether it's a corporation or a a you
know a union anyone that can provide a
lot of money
uh you need to do things that are in
their interest
and so what is usually sacrificed by
these politicians
is the national interest doing what's
right for the country is secondary to
doing what's right for themselves and
also
in order to be as successful as a
politician you have to be a really good
liar and that's probably why a lot of
lawyers go into politics because lawyers
you know they're paid to lie I mean you
have to argue your client's case even if
you know they're wrong right and you
have to put on a defense or whatever it
is and and so lawyers are generally
pretty good liars and so they they they
they be they become politicians because
if you're honest and you tell the truth
you're not going to have a career in
politics you're you're just not gonna
even if you manage to get elected
telling the truth you're not going to
stay in office telling the truth so you
got to lie so here's the situation so
you've had Decades of politicians buying
their re-election by promising voters
something for nothing because
unfortunately that's what a lot of
Voters want they want something from the
government so if you're running for
office like I ran for office in in 2010
I was in Connecticut uh but you know all
I promised was more freedom I'm going to
leave you alone I'm going to repeal
government laws regulations I'm gonna
I'm Gonna Leave You free to do what you
want and I'm not going to interfere with
you some people like that message but a
lot of people that's not what they want
they don't want to be free they want to
be taken care of they want to know what
are you going to give me what stuff am I
going to get if I vote for you right
what free stuff and so yeah well that's
attractive in the short term especially
if you're not paying attention right and
lots people don't pay that much
attention to political discounts and so
if you offer something tangible and
immediate that's grip short-term
attention and that can be an effective
strategy yeah and if you and so it's
this proclivity to gift in this manner
that to the drives inflation do you want
to define inflation yeah I will decide I
know exactly what we're talking about
yeah yeah I will I'm getting there but
and it's even worse when it comes to
trying to take away something like if
you want to cut a program spending
that's even worse because once a voter
has something nobody wants to take it
away in fact even some of the
politicians
let's say Republicans United States that
might have opposed certain government
welfare type programs
you know when they started once they're
in place even those people won't vote to
take them away that's how how a danger
it is so the situation is you've had all
these politicians who have promised so
much stuff
that the taxpayers can't deliver and of
course when politicians
want to give voters something they don't
want them to pay for it so they want to
spend money but they don't want to raise
taxes because governments don't have any
money they only have the money they take
they have to take money from the people
in order to give money back to the
people and and so if the government's
taking your money that you don't like so
with paper money
which unfortunately we have now fiat
currency where the governments don't
need gold real money they could just
create paper money out of thin air right
they could just manufacture it digitally
and there it is
that enables governments to spend
without collecting taxes they run these
large deficits and they're able to print
the difference and hand out that money
so they can give people money without
also taking the money away and now they
don't mind taking money away from rich
people because you know there's not as
many of those right so they don't lose
as many votes although certain rich
people can donate a lot to their
campaigns which often you know prevents
the taxes from from getting too high but
inflation I asked for the definition
inflation is really just another
tax
because governments create inflation and
inflation is also probably one of the
most misunderstood words in the English
language and deliberately so I think
governments around the world kind of led
the campaign to redefine inflation so if
you go back to the origin of the word
and if you if you have a dictionary even
from the 1980s a Webster's dictionary
you'll get the real definition of
inflation so inflation is an expansion
of the money supply that's all it is
deflation is a contraction of the money
supply so if you even think about the
word inflate
inflate is to expand
like a balloon if you if you fill a
balloon with air it expands so with
inflation what's being expanded is the
money supply
and who expands the money supply
governments you know or they they do it
generally now through a central bank but
it's the central banks of these
governments that are expanding the money
supply now when you expand the money
supply you have more money
well if you have more money but you
don't have more stuff to buy well the
price of everything goes up that's just
basic economic supply and demand the
more money there is the less each
individual monetary unit is worth and
now prices go up now what governments
have done is they've said price is going
up that's inflation no it's not that is
the consequence of inflation because
prices don't expand prices go up and
down as a result of inflation now what
happens is sometimes
prices don't go up but you still have
inflation and that's because without
that inflation prices would have gone
down
and if prices don't go down because
government creates inflation that still
represents a loss to the people because
they lost the benefit of lower prices
because in capitalism the tendency of
capitalism is to reduce prices that's
why it's so good because you keep coming
up with better ways of producing more
efficient ways economies of scale if you
look at the CPI for example in the
United States in in 1800 and then you
look at the same CPI in 1900 and they
have the data prices were cut in half
you had a hundred year period where you
had deflation or you know the money or
prices falling for 100 years
uh and that was a good thing you know
all the politicians now tell us that we
need prices to go up that we must have
inflation you know the way they Define
it of two percent a year why why do
prices have to go up every year why
can't they go down every year isn't that
better if stuff gets cheaper you know if
the cost of living goes down of course
it is but these politicians are trying
to sell this lie to the public that
Rising prices are somehow necessary for
Prosperity that if prices don't go up
okay so let me sum up let me sum up what
you've said so the first thing you said
that I think is worthy of note for
people to remember is that
the price of something is a function of
the ratio of the money available to the
goods available
and so if you make money twice as
available then things cost twice as much
and that's and then you Defined
inflation you Defined inflation in that
regard you said inflation isn't prices
going up inflation is the value of money
going down
and so it isn't because things are
becoming more expensive it's because
there's more money chasing the same
amount or fewer items now you could
imagine an inflation in a particular
sector that would emerge because that
thing has become more scarce but General
inflation is a reflection of the
inflation of the money supply right then
you said well here's here's the let me
just finish the summary you said there's
drivers of that inflation of the money
supply and the basic driver is that
because we have a fiat currency that
isn't paid to something
um permanent let's say like gold
and because politicians can create money
by printing it they're incentivized to
do so because they can offer people who
aren't paying much attention cheap gifts
for nothing
and the fastest way to pay for that
because they don't want to raise taxes
is to increase the money supply and then
you might say and this is where we could
bring this home to land is well what's
so bad about that is that we defer our
expenses into the future people get more
free stuff from the government there's a
bit of a tax that's the inflation tax
let's say but all in all the system
works pretty well but you started this
whole discussion by saying the biggest
threat to the financial Integrity of
people individuals over the long run is
inflation and so why does that pose the
Cardinal danger to long-term Financial
Security and prosperity for people yeah
well first of all it's not it's not
working well that that is the problem it
it worked much better when we had honest
money when we were on a gold standard uh
if governments wanted to spend money
they needed gold and where did they get
it they had to collect taxes because
they couldn't create the gold it needed
to be mined and and so it was an honest
system
um and it it was discipline on
politicians now the politicians don't
want to be disciplined any more than you
know teenagers want to chaperone at the
prom right so you know they want to they
want to do a lot of stuff that The
Chaperone won't allow and so gold uh was
keeping politicians in check but to your
point about individual prices you can't
confuse prices individually will go up
and down based on the supply and demand
but if the price of one thing goes up
it's going to necessitate the price of
something else to go down uh and so the
general level of prices won't change uh
it's only when you have the expansion of
the money supply that the price of
everything goes up because the value of
money is going down and so now you need
more money to to buy stuff but the
problem now is because these governments
have run such enormous deficits uh and
it you know inflated you know the
housing bubble that popped in 2008 the
US and then uh a decade or more of
massive deficit spent ending
quantitative easing programs and by the
way quantitative easing is inflation
they basically
get you know taken inflation and put a
nice sounding name to it because
quantitative easing is printing money
and buying government bonds that that's
inflation but if the politicians said
our policy is inflation you know the
public doesn't like that so they said no
we're doing quantitative easing and
somehow that sounds you know more
palatable than inflation but they've
created so much and and for years and
years these Central Bankers were telling
us that inflation is too low we don't
have enough inflation because it's not
two percent and again we don't need
prices to go up you know and the reason
they say that price prices have to go up
is they claim that we won't buy stuff
that if we think prices are going to go
down we'll just hold off on buying
indefinitely waiting for a cheaper price
and the economy is going to collapse and
that's a bunch of BS because you buy
things when you need them and when you
can afford them I mean if if that was
true nobody would own a cell phone
nobody would own a laptop computer
nobody would have a television that
because all those things get cheaper
every year yet we keep buying them so
it's nonsense that we won't buy if price
is going down in fact price is going
down create demand if you can't afford
something the way to have to buy it is
for the price to go down and then you
can afford it and then you buy it but
they've created so much inflation
when they said it was too low that now
it's exploded right you've got
double-digit inflation or high single
digit inflation pretty much in all the
invest economies in the world
and no government anywhere in the world
is willing to actually do what it takes
to reduce inflation because a they have
to accept responsibility for creating it
and then B they have to significantly
reduce government spending and or raise
taxes on on middle class uh voters and
neither of those choices are politically
expedient and so politicians now are
under more pressure than ever to
continue to finance their spending
through inflation so the inflation tax
is going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger uh every year
and the reason that that's such a
problem is it's really the worst
possible tax because it impacts the
people the most who can afford it the
least it's the middle class the Working
Poor uh and the retirees who are living
off of fixed income uh they end up
paying the inflation tax the most uh
they have some savings they have a
pension they have an annuity a cash
value and insurance policies all this
stuff gets uh destroyed wealthier people
who tend to own assets and who have more
good debt right bad debt is Consumer
Debt you go out and you borrow money and
you spend it you buy a consumer good you
buy a TV with your credit card and
that's bad debt or you take a vacation
and you pay for it on a credit card but
if you buy an asset particularly an
income producing asset a piece of
property uh if you a business a comp
stock if you borrow money and you buy an
asset and that asset is appreciating and
generating income
inflation is your friend inflation helps
you out because it wipes out the value
of your debt and you still have the
asset so wealthy people very wealthy
people if they invest the right way will
benefit from inflation whereas Ordinary
People are going to get hurt
have you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider to actually stop people
from monitoring your online activity you
need expressvpn think about all the
times you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop
hotel or even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode it expressvpn is an app
that encrypts all of your network data
and reroutes it through a network of
secure servers so that your private
online activity stays private expressvpn
works on all your devices and is super
easy to use the app has one button you
tap it to connect and your browsing
activity is secure stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy by
visiting expressvpn.com Jordan that's
expresvpn.com Jordan and get three extra
months free
expressvpn.com Jordan
[Music]
so inflation is particularly hard on
non-entrepreneurial savers
so people who've put put away a certain
store of value maybe that's in a pension
who aren't invested in some active
Enterprise that could be generating
Revenue it just devastates them and if
it's four percent a year they lose what
what does that mean they lose half the
value of their investment in like
four percent a year would be something
like 10 years
yeah and so unfortunately it's going to
be a lot higher than than four percent
yeah let's talk about that for a second
so two things two questions about that
that are that come along with what
you've already laid out the first
question is
how is the inflation rate calculated
that's mysterious right because yeah
that's it Consumer Price Index that's
another big part of the fraud because
certainly in America and I know a lot
more about the U.S CPI let's say than I
do about cpis in other countries but my
assumption is that you know the
politicians are being dishonest
everywhere because you know the
inflation rate it's like a report card
and if our kids were responsible for
grading their own report cards it
wouldn't be as shocker if they came home
with all A's right so that this is the
problem that we've hired the government
to grade its own you know is its own Pro
success you know in the economy because
High inflation would would be would be
bad
um so the government again when they're
measuring inflation and they're looking
at prices they're looking at an effect
they're not looking at the thing itself
but
over the years
governments have changed the methodology
for measuring price increases so the CPI
that we use today
is nothing like the one that we use say
in the 1970s yeah that's exactly what I
want to focus on because so the CPI for
everyone listing that's the Consumer
Price Index and it's in principle please
correct me if I've got any of this wrong
it's the average cost of something like
a standard basket of goods that's what a
question then is which Goods yeah okay
so let's go into that it used to be
there was the basket didn't change they
picked a basket and they just measured
the same basket
year after year and so you could see the
changes now the basket changes the
politicians decide what to put in the
basket and when to take out
and generally they take out stuff that's
gone up and they put in stuff that
hasn't gone up as much there's all this
substitution there's a lot of other
indexes that they use where they have
hedonics or it is CPI there's hedonics
and so what hedonics is is the
statisticians who compute the CPI they
look at a product
and they don't use the actual price they
subjectively decide if they think that
product got better
and if they think it got better they
adjust the price down
now maybe it did get better and a lot of
times stuff gets worse
and they don't
they don't adjust for that
um like let's say they're looking at
airline prices and they just look at the
ticket price and they say wait a minute
but you're charged extra for luggage
you're charged extra for a blanket
you're charged extra for food oh you
know they just look at the price you
know a lot of quality has gone down and
a lot of things that hasn't been
captured and you know I did this
exercise I did this a long time ago in
2013 and I made a YouTube video about it
but
I just did this for kicks
I looked at the CPI in 2013. and
according to the CPI over the prior 10
years
um the the price of newspapers and
magazines had gone up about 30 percent
according to the CPI in 2013 magazines
and newspapers were 30 percent more
expensive than they were in 2003. well I
decided to check because it's easy to do
you know you could just go on the
internet and you could see a picture of
those magazines because they put the
price right on the cover so I took about
20 I took like 20 of the most circulated
newspapers and magazines in the country
and I just looked at what the price was
in 2003 and then I took the exact same
magazines and I looked at the price on
the cover and I just compared it over
the the 10 years and what I found was
that the actual increase in price wasn't
30 it was a hundred and thirty percent
so the question is where did that extra
100 go because you know that those are
the prices so obviously the CPI is
rigged in such a way as to have a a
number it's not that people lie when
they calculate like they get a certain
number and they say oh no that's too
high the methodology that is used has
been engineered
to mask the real degree to which prices
are rising you also pointed to something
else that's a fundamental flaw if your
reasoning is correct which is that if
inflation is best construed as ratio of
money to Goods merely calculating
inflation as a consequence of price
increase doesn't capture the essential
element of the inflation because that's
a huge problem too because let's say
prices should have gone down by three
percent and instead they go up by two
percent
that's five percent inflation in that my
cost of living is five percent higher
than it would have been
um had you not had the inflation and
again if you think about inflation as a
tax when the government taxes you
legitimately let's say through a sales
tax or an income tax whatever the
government takes your money money that
you had goes to the government and then
the government takes that money and
gives it to somebody else right you lose
your money but when they tax you through
inflation they don't take any of your
money you get to keep your money but
they print new money and they give that
money to somebody else now when that's
somebody else spends that money that he
didn't earn it drives up your prices so
now you pay more so the government
didn't take your money they took your
purchasing power
so it's the same thing and you know
another thing about our CPI that they
how they changed
is Once Upon a Time back in the 70s
housing prices were in the CPI and and
so were rents
and and that's about a third of the CPI
which is shelter but somewhere along the
way they decided to use something called
owner's equivalent rent instead of
actual rent or actual home prices now
what is owner's equivalent rent well
it's a fiction that they made up that
nobody actually pays apparently uh the
government calls people at random
and asks them if they own their home how
much do they think they could rent it
for if they were to rent it and they
keep track of those numbers
now I don't know like you know who
they're asking I mean I've owned homes
for a long time I've never gotten a call
from a government guy wanting to know
what I think I could rent my house for
but if you're not a landlord and you're
not in the rental market how the hell do
you know what you could rent in your
house for it's such a ridiculous way to
try to measure the cost of Shelter by
using a number okay so let me okay so
let me ask you a question about that
because I've really been curious about
that because
it's obvious the K the case in Canada in
particular like housing and rent prices
have skyrocketed in the last eight years
and that's not reflected in the
inflation statistics and that seems to
be a major oversight at least according
to one line of argumentation because
that's one-third of what people spend
their money on now you could argue this
is where it gets complicated as far as I
can tell that
if what you've bought is an asset that
generates income and its value goes up
that's actually not a cost to you it's
an advantage you already made reference
well only if you if you own the asset
yes if you own it if you want to buy it
and the price has gone up it's a
disadvantage right because now the
assets that you want to buy are more
more costly
right so does that imply that a proper
CPI that would include the cost of
shelter would be calculated on the basis
of those who want to buy rather than
those who already own yeah because I'm
trying to figure out how to measure
inflation properly here right you're
very complicated problem if you already
own a home
then the cost of buying another one is
not as important to you of course a lot
of people that own homes they may want
to buy bigger homes as their families
grow and and so it would be but for
those people what's important are uh
your maintenance costs
your insurance costs your property taxes
uh there are a lot of other factors that
would be significant to you if you don't
own if you're a renter then obviously
rent is of primary importance to you
you're you're paying rent there's all
sorts of valid ways that the government
could measure shelter as a component of
the cost of living but in the United
States they don't choose any of those
valid ways they choose another way and
they're doing that because they want the
number to be lower they don't want to
report High inflation and they even do
this as part of the GNP because when
they deport report GDP they don't even
do GNP anymore it's GDP now that they
report gross domestic product
in order to get the number they have to
deflate it every there's a deflator
which adjusts the GDP for prices and the
government always underestimates that
deflator so the GDP looks bigger than it
really is because in many cases
economies are actually Contracting in
real terms but because the government is
dishonest in the way it reports it it
reports economic growth even though
there is no real growth it's inflation
which creates the illusion of growth
that's another reason that politicians
like inflation and of course when
inflation drives up the stock market and
the real estate market people think
they're richer right because oh my house
has gone way up my stock but it hasn't
gone up your money has gone down
right but people don't necessarily
connect those dots uh you know they they
think they're they think they're
wealthier but also if you think about as
I said earlier inflation benefits
debtors it's a transfer of wealth from
creditors to debtors who are the biggest
debtors in the world governments and the
biggest
most highly indebted government is the
United States government we have 32
trillion dollars of funded debt almost
and our unfunded liabilities commitments
that have been made where they didn't
borrow the money but they're on the hook
like guaranteed student loans or a
guaranteed pensions Social Security
Medicare all that stuff that's like a
hundred trillion so when the government
creates inflation they repudiate
enormous amounts of their debt and so
the governments have massive incentives
to create inflation but then they have
massive incentives to lie about it and
pretend it's not as bad as it is and
blame other people which is the main
reason that they redefine inflation from
the expansion of the money supply to
Rising prices because when you know
inflation is an expansion of the money
supply then you know who causes it it's
the government you can't blame greedy
corporations for it you can't blame
Putin for it Putin doesn't print our
money
we do the Federal Reserve does and so
when politicians can redefine inflation
they can they can blame everybody but
themselves
okay so so let me ask you a kind of a
modified Ponzi scheme question because
this is something that's bedeviled me so
I understand that so I have two
questions I understand that getting the
measurements of something as fundamental
as inflation correct is absolutely
necessary so one of the things I've
wondered is like why aren't there
independent teams of economists who
generate various true estimates of
inflation make them public so that the
public itself could gather a basket of
independent estimates and know for
themselves what the inflation rate is
very curious about that well they have
one other well I mean there's a website
who's reliable who's reliable
yeah you know well I think the least
reliable would be the government
right yeah yeah you don't want their
statistics because they're completely
biased right you know it's like you know
the mafia is not going to give you
accurate statistics on crime right so
um you got to look to Independent
sources but
um I think it's kind of obvious though
if you understand what inflation is and
you see the enormity I mean the United
States is running two trillion dollar a
year plus deficits now uh and
technically we're not even in a
recession the deficits are going to get
even bigger uh when this next recession
starts but how are we financing those
deficits it's it's inflation there's
just no other way they'll look at the
the Federal Reserves balance sheet so we
know that inflation is going to be a
significant threat it's going to reduce
the value of money and so that has to be
the single most important factor in
driving your decisions on savings on
investing
um you know and and even for in this day
and age if you don't have a lot of money
to invest you know I I've been saying
this for years to people I started
talking about it several years ago
people have to stock up on things you
know you know buy things that you're
going to use in a year or two buy it now
because it's going to be a lot more
expensive if you wait why hold on to the
cash if the cash is going to lose value
uh just buy the things that you're
actually going to need because those
things will retain their value if you're
planning on using them
so here's the Ponzi scheme question
so
because of the efficiencies of the
capitalist system
free market system let's say
we are generally able to produce more
for less and in some instances we seem
to be doing that faster and faster so
consumer electronics are a good example
and price of computation and so forth
and so what that means is that
independent of inflation because of
technological progress things will get
cheaper in the future the future will be
richer than the present so then you
might say if you're a politician you say
well if that's the case and if that's
invariably the the case then why not
defer our debt to the Future like
essentially why not borrow from the
future because the future is going to be
wealthier than the present and then I
wonder like if we had a three percent
increment in actual productivity per
year
then maybe we could tolerate a two
percent inflation rate because
fundamentally
the tendency for things to get cheaper
because of enhanced productivity would
be balanced by that inflationary
proclivity so are the politicians could
you make a case that the politicians are
making a good bet because they're
throwing the debt into the future when
we're going to be richer no well they
they are making a politically
opportunistic decision yeah fair enough
because they're they're telling the
voters hey don't worry about it your
grandkids will pay for it right or
whatever uh and and right of course not
all voters have kids right some voters
you know don't have kids and so what do
they care if somebody else's
grandchildren uh pay for their for their
program but the only time you could
justify
borrowing from the future
is if you are creating something that
future uh people will benefit from let's
say a capital investment let's say the
government is going to build a bridge
and that bridge is going to be there for
100 years right uh and and people who
aren't even born yet are going to
benefit from that bridge okay maybe they
can sell bonds to finance the
construction of that bridge that future
people will end up paying because
they're going to have the benefit of
that bridge so you can make an argument
for debt to support that but if we're
going to borrow money just to pay for
welfare benefits or Social Security
benefits where we're leaving our
children and grandchildren with nothing
but a bill right they don't have a
bridge or a capital asset uh the money's
been spent I see so your argument
basically is is that if you're borrowing
from the future isn't designed
specifically to drive productivity let's
say then it's a degenerating bet yeah I
don't think it's borrowing from the
future I think it's stealing from the
future you're trying yeah okay fair
enough and and yeah but you know a lot
of this stuff is going to backfire
because I think the current generation
is going to pay for a lot of this stuff
because
the dollar is going to collapse you know
we could have hyperinflation and and
because the future Generations are not
going to pay this they're you know
they're they're they're going to leave
that you know they'll leave the
countries that because they're not going
to want to be subjected to the
confiscatory tax rates when they can't
get commensurate benefits from
government they're going to leave uh the
the currency is going to collapse in
value and we're already there I mean
we're already at that point because
you're talking about this
intergenerational Ponzi scheme that's
really what Social Security is I mean it
wasn't created that way in the 1930s
when Roosevelt uh first uh concocted
this social security and it was totally
unconstitutional and unfortunate that
that we haven't but the idea was that it
was like Insurance the government was
going to take the money and invest it
and then when everybody was older you
would get paid your benefits and they
even called the taxes premiums but the
whole thing was a con because it never
was Insurance because the government
never invested the money they spent the
money and now they gave themselves an
IOU they created these things called
trust funds and so what would happen is
the government would collect the money
from Social Security then they would
take the Social Security money and spend
it on whatever military or whatever
they're doing but then they would put an
IOU in the government trust fund in the
form of a bond and then they would say
oh we have an asset in this trust fund
we have a bond that's not an asset it's
it's your own debt it's like if I write
myself a check for a million dollars I
can't take that uncashed check and claim
I've got a million dollar asset no I
mean it's also a million dollar
liability so there never was any money
in Social Security they spent it all
their the system is broke and now they
have to keep raising taxes on the
workers but now they won't even raise
taxes on the workers so they just keep
they create inflation to pay for Social
Security
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
documentary logos and literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning into a begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripture memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johan goodberg science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
okay so let me let me offer another Rosy
scenario sort of like the boring from
the future scenario so I've been
thinking about this issue of fiat
currency and the fact that the currency
is on moored
but we have a situation in the world now
where every currency is unmoored right
and so you might say no matter what form
of money you use you're making a bad bet
you're relying on something unreliable
but if you're going to rely on something
unreliable
you should rely on the least unreliable
currency
right and so then you might say well the
least unreliable currency becomes by
default the standard and the US has
managed that for 50 years 60 years and
so why isn't it the case because you
said for example well people who are
subject to unfair tax because of future
deferral of debt will leave but I could
say yeah but there won't be anywhere
better to go I know there will be and so
the the whole world doesn't doesn't you
know there have those tax rates of a
certain country you know
um Saddles it's
yeah future generations with too big a
debt burden
um those you know that they could leave
and go to a country that doesn't have
that demographic problem that big
um of a dead burden and and and and of
course so you think there'll still be
enough call even if everyone's on fiat
currency and if all the currencies are
corrupt you still think there'll be
enough variability oh yeah corruption so
that people will vote with their feet
like they are in the U.S moving from
correct Democrats correct Republic and
states and the idea that you know it's
the you have to settle for the least bad
uh currency and again currency isn't
even really money money is a commodity
gold was money silver you know it would
be money
uh legitimate currency which is backed
by real money is currency what we have
now is fiat currency and and both fiat
currency and and legitimate currency are
substitutes for money they're not actual
money but they substitute and they can
function as money but they're not really
money in the real sense of how you
define money as the most marketable
commodity which is would be money but
people have been saying well you know
the dollar is the cleanest shirt in the
hamper
and but I I think the dollar only
appears clean
because of its status as the reserve
currency
and I think that status is in Jeopardy
and when it's lost then the dollar is
going to be the the by far the dirtiest
shirt in in in in that hamper so so and
okay so two questions from that so first
of all maybe you could walk everybody
through why the government is the
biggest debtor because people aren't
really clear even for example about the
difference between the deficit and the
debt and they don't know what the debt
means to them in real terms because it's
always expressed in these huge numbers
like 132 trillion it's like no one knows
what that means but they could figure
that out if they knew how much of that
debt they were responsible for or their
family so you've got you've got two
first of all why is the government the
big debtor well you've got the national
debt which is the accumulation of every
Year's budget deficit and then you've
got the the annual budget deficit which
adds to the total debt
um but what I'm talking about creditors
versus debtors Nations can either be a
creditor Nation or a debtor Nation a
creditor nation is a nation in which the
world owes it money more money that it
owes the world a debtor Nation owes the
world more than it's owed so prior to
the US going off the gold standard in
1971 and in fact all the way up to
probably the early 1980s
the United States was the world's
biggest creditor Nation right we we
generated tremendous amounts of wealth
um under a Freer economy than the one we
have today and one that was governed by
the disciplines of a gold standard so we
became the world's wealthiest creditor
Nation today after 50 years of Fiat
money America is not only the world's
biggest debtor Nation
America owes more money than all the
other debtor nations of the world
combined right that's how uh much our
financial position has eroded now when
the dollar became the reserve currency
it became the reserve currency because
of America's Financial and Industrial
might we were the world's biggest
creditor Nation we also had huge trade
surpluses now we have massive trade
deficits I mean over a trillion dollars
a year but when the dollar became the
reserve currency we made everything
you know all the Consumer Electronics
that are now made in Japan or Korea or
China all that stuff was made in America
I mean if you wanted anything we made it
in this country in America and so since
everybody wanted American Products
everybody needed American dollars to buy
them and the American dollar was as good
as gold because if you had dollars you
had gold if you had 35 dollars you could
get an ounce of gold from the government
it was convertible and so under those
conditions the US dollar became the
reserve currency but today
the the dollar would never be the
reserve currency today if it wasn't
already there right nobody would pick
the dollar given our financial position
our trade-in balances but you know it's
been the reserve currency because you
know for the tradition of the fact that
it's been
but
in order for the world
to to maintain this status it's very
expensive for the world it's a huge
benefit for America I said we have a
trillion dollar a year trade deficit
that means the world has to supply
America with a million dollars worth of
merchandise for which it doesn't get
paid right it doesn't it doesn't get
products you know most countries in
order to export have to I mean in order
to import have to export you have to
export something in order to pay for
your Imports well we don't have to
export anything we just print money and
Export that well that costs nothing but
the rest of the world has to produce
real stuff and and use resources land
labor and capital to produce products so
Americans get to live beyond their means
because of the dollar status but the
rest of the world collectively lives
beneath its means and of course it's not
um uh consistent because some countries
uh have to live even further below their
means depending on how big a trade
Surplus they have with the United States
that's how much they're subsidizing the
US economy so a lot of the Emerging
Markets uh bearing even uh bigger uh uh
uh burden of preserving the dollar
status
and and so I think the world is starting
to move away from the dollar not only
because of the economic cost
of maintaining it but now we have raised
the political risks if you look at what
the Biden Administration did with Russia
the unprecedented sanctions
on Russia
this has really highlighted the
tremendous risk that every Sovereign
Nation assumes by being beholden to the
dollar
because it puts tremendous power in the
hands of the United States it's like
putting a noose around your neck and
then throwing throwing it over a tree to
America who's holding the other end then
you're hoping that they don't pull I
mean nobody wants to really be in that
position especially if you're a country
like China where you know we've kind of
made China our enemy but in reality
China provides America with the largest
annual subsidy they're our biggest uh uh
uh trade deficit is with China so they
Supply us with more merchandise than
anybody else and they're our largest
creditor now some people say it's Japan
uh but no it's actually China because
you have to take Hong Kong because Hong
Kong is part of China so if you take all
the treasuries that Hong Kong owns and
the treasuries that China owns that's
more than Japan so they're our biggest
Banker they Supply us with credit they
Supply us with merchandise right that's
all going to end right China is going to
wean itself of that okay so well so
let's let's go after that so you said
and let me see if I got the reasons
right you said well the American dollar
could stand as the
um fundamental currency because it had
come off the gold standard but had still
benefited from that it was
extraordinarily productive it ran huge
trade surpluses it was a dynamic
expanding rich country with a very
stable currency so it could run on that
for a long time and and you said however
now if people looked at the American
economic situation the American dollar
without that historical context there's
no way the US dollar would be the
reserve currency but then we're back to
the dirty shirt in hamper problem and I
know the Russians and the and the
Chinese and the Brazilians Etc are
wrestling with that they're trying to
move people away to some degree from the
dollar as a reserve currency but like
nobody in the right mind is going to
trust the Chinese currency so where so
where do people go if it's not the
American dollar that's going to be the
standard for all the reasons you laid
out well you know the Euro doesn't look
better really and certainly you have to
be insane to use Chinese currency I
think see that that is the false choice
that everybody thinks we have to make
one of the reasons that people are so
arrogant particularly in America that
the dollar status is not in jeopardy and
so that we can keep on running these
huge deficits we can create keep on
creating inflation and the world's got
no choice right but the state with a
dollar because are they going to go to
the euro are they going to go to the Yen
you know the pound I mean they're
winning B I agree all of those
currencies also have problems
and so do you really want to switch from
one flawed fiat currency to another even
if those other Fiat currencies may be
less flawed than the dollar right
do you really want to make that shift I
don't think that that's what's going to
happen what everybody is missing is that
there is an alternative
to the dollar that doesn't involve
another fiat currency and that's gold
that is real money everybody forgets
that for thousands of years gold was
money it was money because it worked now
over the course of time we had paper
currencies that would arise and fall I
mean hundreds of years ago they were
paper currencies that are now worthless
and you don't even know their names you
know they come and go but gold has has
stayed you know gold works as money and
so I think what these central banks are
going to do is as they get out of
dollars they will just increase their
Holdings of gold gold will be the
monetary anchor gold will be the reserve
monetary asset just the way it was
before the dollar it wasn't the British
pound I mean the British pound was a
dominant currency but gold was what
everybody owned the British back the
pound do you see any do you see any
evidence that some of these alternate
currencies are starting to back their
currency claims with gold oh yeah you
can what's happening on the central
banks are now buying more gold than
they've bought in in in decades
especially a lot of the uh you know the
Emerging Market countries not even maybe
so much the United States isn't buying
any gold and maybe you know some of the
more mature uh countries but a lot of
other countries that had predominantly
held dollars and then to a lower degree
Euros or Yen or pounds these countries
are increasingly buying gold that's why
gold is at a record high it goes around
two thousand dollars an ounce but in
terms of just about every other currency
on the planet gold has been hitting
all-time record highs uh and again
that's not really gold going up that's
all these Fiat currencies going down but
what are the reasons that countries
would want gold as opposed to the dollar
is the US government doesn't have any
control over it you know gold is an
asset that's not also somebody else's
liability and nobody could create it you
have to mine it no one country you know
has the advantage so you know why would
you want to take away
uh that that privilege that the United
States has and just bestow it on
somebody else who is going to abuse it
the same way I mean the United States
abused that privilege that we had and we
we we exported all this inflation to the
world we took advantage of the this the
position that we were in uh so why would
you want to put another nation in in a
position to similarly take advantage of
the world it's much better to go back to
to honest money and again even when we
were on Bretton Woods before you know
1971 and we were on the dollar standard
it was because the dollar was backed by
gold again if you held dollars you held
gold that's where the saying came from
the dollar is as good as gold in fact
the legal definition of a dollar is a is
a weight of gold that's what a dollar is
dollars are gold the the the paper
currency that circulated Federal Reserve
notes are not dollars they are notes of
the Federal Reserve initially the those
Federal Reserve notes were payable in
dollars the dollars were the gold that
the Federal Reserve notes paid because
if you think about what a note is a note
is a promise to pay something a Federal
Reserve Note is supposed to pay
something well what did it pay it paid
gold it paid dollars today Federal
Reserve notes pay nothing their ious
nothing the Federal Reserve is not
obligated to give you anything I mean if
you have a ten dollar bill okay so
people people might object and they and
they have
that well gold is just another arbitrary
standard of value it has some intrinsic
worth it's useful for jewelry it's
useful for certain industrial
applications but it's just another
psychologically valuable currency
without any intrinsic value and so it
shouldn't be a repository of value in
principle that's any more stable than
let's say a well-managed or even a badly
managed fiat currency and so what do you
what do you why is it that gold has
proved itself let's say over centuries
or Millennia as a storehouse of value
what is it about gold
intrinsically let's say that seems to
have given it that edge the idea that
gold doesn't have any intrinsic value is
just pure nonsense it's obviously
politicians have a vested interest in in
trying to diminish gold as a monetary
alternative to the Fiat system and even
now you have a lot out of cryptocurrency
enthusiasts who say the same thing well
you know gold has no value because they
want to justify something like Bitcoin
which also has no value and say well
gold worked as money and it has no value
so so Bitcoin could work well it's not
true that gold has no value gold is the
most valuable the most useful metal on
the periodic table gold became money
because it was such a valuable commodity
but gold has a lot of properties that
make it uniquely qualified to be money
more so than than other Commodities
that's why gold was so successful over
the centuries as money because people
preferred to use it as money it wasn't
governments that decided gold is going
to be money
the people decided that gold was going
to be money and once the people decided
that gold was going to be money if you
were a king you know well you would tax
people in Gold because if you wanted to
pay your soldiers to protect you your
soldiers wanted gold right so it was the
money created in the free market and it
beat out all other forms of money
because gold you know a gold coin uh all
they're all all the same you could melt
gold down and you can make it into coins
uh it's fungible it's portable it's
divisible but the other aspect of goal
that is the key you can save gold
because if I have an ounce of gold in
100 years in a thousand years it's
exactly the same it doesn't lose any of
its properties and in fact even if I
take my gold and I make you know I make
a ring out of it or I I use it to make a
watch right
you can melt this ring down and you get
your gold back and it's exactly the way
it was you could do something else with
it there's really no other metal you can
keep using it over and over and over
again I mean they fill teeth with gold
if you find somebody buried in the
ground you know you could take their
fillings and you know the Gold's still
there you know there treasure ships from
the 1400s 1500s they sink if they
recover the wreckage the only thing
that's still there is the goal it's an
it looks exactly the way it looked when
the sink when the ship sank 500 years
ago so from a point of savings because
money has to satisfy three primary
conditions two of them are a unit of
account an immediate exchange but the
third one is the store of value
and that's important
because it's also makes it possible to
do loans that I can borrow money you can
lend money and you can be repaid and you
know that the money that you're going to
get repaid is going to retain its value
and so that's something that gold that
gold does better than than other metals
but
the the value of gold even if I'm not
using my gold today as a metal let's say
I have gold stored in a safe and you say
well you know you're not using it for
anything that's true but I'm preserving
the future use of that gold somebody in
the future is going to need that gold
and so I'm storing it right now
because you know there are more uses for
gold that are discovered all the time
because of its very unique properties
I'm sure in a hundred years or a
thousand years
there will be more uses for gold than
there are now
and and so okay so let me where are they
push you on the crypto front for a
second so
so you know I've been contemplating
permanent storage storehouses of value
concerned about such phenomenon that
we've been discussing as inflation and
potentially hyperinflation Which is far
from rare even among developed countries
I think you have a one percent chance if
you live in a developed country of uh
hyperinflation incident at some point in
your life it's something like that but
anyways the cryptocurrency people and I
think the Bitcoin people have made this
case the best is that they've managed to
duplicate gold in its important elements
in that they've produced a storehouse of
value that can't be corrupted because
it's blockchained and distributed and
that's a nice argument that also gets
more scarce with time which was quite
the brilliant
um technological innovation that
requires work to
obtain and so that's the Bitcoin mining
but that is also easily distributable
digitally and so it's out of the hands
of governments it's an uncorruptable
store of value it's widely distributed
and it's easily moved and so you know
that's not that that accounts for a fair
number of the properties that you
described a money a moment a monetary
unit had to possess so
what do you think of crypto in general
but more specifically about Bitcoin
because I think it's king of the cryptos
and
do you think there's a case to be made
that gold has an advantage that crypto
cannot duplicate and then we might ask
well what if you had a gold-backed
crypto
because maybe then you could have the
best of both worlds so so what are your
thoughts about the I mean bitcoin's done
pretty well for a currency that doesn't
exist you know that's not government
mandated Etc it's it's stored its value
there's a lot of well variability oh
first of all but Bitcoin isn't a store
value because you can't store something
that you don't have right first you have
to have the value so as I said Gold's
value is its use as a metal right that's
what you're storing is the future use of
gold and metal whether you're going to
use it in jewelry or as a conductor in
electronics or in medicine whatever it
is you're you're storing that uh Bitcoin
only has a price doesn't have value
price is something that you pay right
value is something that you get when you
buy Bitcoin you pay a price but you get
no real value
um and now I agree the price of Bitcoin
has gone way up from when it was first
started where you know you could get
multiple Bitcoins for a fraction of a
penny or a dollar whatever they started
next to nothing and at one point people
were paying almost seventy thousand
dollars for for a Bitcoin
um currently it's around 27 000 as we're
recording this
um so depending on when you bought you
you potentially made a lot of money if
you sold if you bought during the Mania
hysteria of 2021 you know you you've
lost a lot of your money if you if you
get out
um but looking at Bitcoin look Bitcoin
did an excellent job of replicating the
qualities that gold has
that made it better money than you know
cattle you know or salt or you know
other Commodities that have been money
right gold did has certain properties
and Bitcoin you know
captured those properties but the most
important property at all
of all is Gold's metallic properties
gold as a commodity Bitcoin has none of
that
and and so
Bitcoin just like a fiat currency what
what gives a fiat currency its value
just confidence people just believe that
it has value they believe that people
will accept it now part of that belief
is driven by governments which declare
it legal tender and which require it for
payment of taxes and so there is some
real demand for dollars if you live in
America there's a demand for euros if
you're in Europe because you have to pay
taxes and if you don't pay taxes they
could put you in jail and so in order to
avoid jail you need the currency that
the the government demands uh but
Bitcoin
is similar to Fiat in that all of its
value comes from faith and confidence
people just believe that people in the
future will want it and they'll pay a
higher price for it except there is no
legal currency status there is no
government really maybe other than El
Salvador I don't know what's going on
over there but there's no government
that is accepting tax payments in
Bitcoin
um so there's no natural demand other
than the speculative demand
from people who think they're going to
get rich I mean people who buy Bitcoin
are buying it because they expect the
price to go up and the people who buy it
from them thinks their the price is
going to go up so it's just greater full
theory that the price is going to go up
and that's what's driving people to buy
it uh it's very cumbersome if you want
to use it as a medium exchange or a unit
of account it's too volatile to be a
unit of account it's too expensive to be
a medium of exchange and it can't be a
store of value uh so it's it's it's not
gold it's you know digital Fool's Gold
but you you hit the nail on the head
when you talked about a crypto that's
actually backed by gold that works that
solves all the problems that bitcoiners
claim
gold has it well you know I can't send
my gold around the world I can't use my
gold to buy a cup of coffee well yes you
can it's a lot better than Bitcoin if I
have gold stored with any third party it
could be a government it could be a
private company it could be anybody
you could tokenize that goal and have a
Bitcoin similar cryptocurrency
that is a digital representation of that
actual goal it's like a warehouse
receipt an IOU for gold and then if I
wanted to give you some of my gold I
wouldn't have to ship you my bar I could
just send you my tokens you know over
the internet and and now the ownership
goes from me to you
um you know it's it's an improvement on
paper money because again initially
paper money came as a substitute for
gold I had my gold stored with a
blacksmith and instead of lugging my
gold around my blacksmith gave me an IOU
and then I could circulate that IOU
because everybody knows the gold is
there and instead of having to get it
they just circulate uh the IOU in in the
paper terms well it's much more
efficient to do it uh crypto digitally
and you can take an ounce of gold or a
gram of gold and divide it you know to
tiny little pieces so that I could buy a
cup of coffee and pay the Barista with
my gold uh using the token uh and it
would be faster and cheaper than Bitcoin
and the difference is when I'm paying
with gold I'm paying with something real
I'm getting one commodity for another
I'm getting coffee and the guy that sold
me coffee is getting gold
um and you can actually denominate the
price in Gold because gold is stable I
mean it could function much better as a
monetary instrument the only thing that
you have you have to trust you have to
trust the third party
but I mean capitalism is all about
trusting third parties I mean private
third parties we we buy an insurance
policy people buy life insurance fire
Insurance health insurance it's all a
third party that's selling you that
policy the policy is only as good as the
third party's ability to to pay you know
how do you you know we have rating
agencies we have capitalism we have
competition for reputation
there is no reason that you can't have
third parties to store your gold and
then you could use it you don't have to
store all of your gold that way you can
keep a lot of your gold yourself but the
goal that you want to use as a media of
exchange uh you can use that uh
digitally and that works much better uh
than Bitcoin you have real value you
have real well I've talked I've talked
to people who have
attempted to produce gold-backed
cryptocurrencies and they've run into
from my understanding a variety of legal
impediments on that front do you know of
anybody who's doing that successfully
and if so
why aren't they uh Prime competitors
let's say in the international market
for Bitcoin I mean the argument you laid
out seems to make sense and so you'd
think well you'd think two things you'd
think given that governments are rushing
to digital currencies and that some
governments would like to displace the
U.S dollar as the reserve currency that
the logical thing to do for some
enterprising country would be to produce
a digital currency that was gold backed
and so what's happening on that front
okay so there's two things first of all
the demand that is mainly coming in
cryptocurrencies including Bitcoin
is to get rich right people want to buy
Bitcoin because they think it's going to
go to the Moon
and so that's really the demand for
cryptocurrencies it's not to have an
alternative as a medium of exchange and
as a unit of account most people that
are buying Bitcoin they still use
dollars or Euros or Pounds in their
transactions they just hoard their
Bitcoin because they think they're going
to get rich
and and so there's no real Demand yet
for a cryptocurrency that's backed by
gold to be used as a medium exchange
people are still content to use their
Fiat currencies for that role
um
but I think that once this crypto bubble
really pops and
the losses you know stack up and and
people get burned and they're no longer
interested in these get rich quick
schemes and they really start to focus
on an alternative
not to get rich but to preserve what
they have right because that's what gold
is Right physical gold is not about
getting rich it's about avoiding
becoming poor it's about avoiding the
inflation tax and and so I think as the
inflation rates get worse throughout you
know the world
there will be more of a demand for an
alternative medium of exchange to these
Fiat currencies that can also store
value you said you said some of that is
happening already you said that many
countries around the world the central
banks are buying gold the central banks
right seems to be a right right so and
and many of those central banks are also
starting to experiment with the idea of
an imposed digital currency well there
there's there's flirting on the market
what they're talking about is a digital
fiat currency that just gives them more
yes I know they just want they and if
they want to eliminate cash it's just
inherently a very oppressive monetary
system that concentrates even more power
in government and diminishes uh
individual liberty and makes it easier
for governments to become more
tyrannical so that's a whole different a
topic but staying on a gold back crypto
so one reason is that there's not a lot
of demand for it yet
the other problem though is that to the
extent that there is some demand
there is such a huge regulatory
impediment and I think it's deliberate
on the part of governments governments
don't want to have to compete with gold
and and so the barrier that a lot of
companies face because it's very easy to
tokenize Gold this is not a hard process
it's the regulatory environment
it's the money laundering laws uh you
know that are there uh that make it very
expensive to get into this
um business
uh because you have to comply with all
these rules and regulations and also you
have the potential for governments to
declare these tokens Securities which
they're not but some government can say
oh it's a it's a security and now it's
got to be registered and you've got to
comply with all these other rules and
regulations so government makes it very
expensive to compete with their Fiat
currencies so what has to happen is the
advantage of a goal back crypto has to
be so large that it could absorb those
costs and that's going to happen because
the inflation is going to be so high but
also you're going to have Sovereign
Nations potentially coming out with
goldback cryptos in the United States
you may have state governments coming
out with their own official
uh gold back uh cryptos uh there it's I
mean all of this is going to happen the
market is going to find solutions to
this problem you know whenever the
government you know has some type of
service that it provides and of course
all government services are going to be
flawed you know we talked about how
capitalism lowers prices governments
raise prices whenever whenever you look
at an industry that that's heavily
regulated education right prices go up
all the time because the government is
so involved that's why it keeps getting
more expensive and the quality goes down
the quality of Education I mean a high
school degree you know 50 years ago is
is way more valuable than a college
degree today even a master's degree so
governments have destroyed especially a
master's degree yeah the governments
have destroyed the value of degrees
while dramatically increasing the price
to to get one so government drives
quality down and price up the free
market does the reverse it drives quite
quality up and and and and and and price
down
government let's say the post office
right post office was a problem and so
then FedEx came along right and okay we
can avoid the post office or more
recently uh governments create
monopolies in taxi cabs well Uber comes
along Lyft comes along and and creates
some competition to these government
monopolies so the same thing is going to
happen with money government money is is
so bad
and it's going to get worse that the
market is going to offer Alternatives
and
yes the government is going to try to
put up roadblocks to protect its
Monopoly But ultimately it won't work
and you know the people will find ways
around it okay okay so well let's turn
on the recommendation front now so and
we can talk a little bit about your
particular business as well so
I would say that one of the threads
running through our conversation is well
first of all you're cautioning people
against the immense danger not only of
inflation but of potential
hyperinflation and you're making the
case that Fiat currencies including the
American dollar are intrinsically weak
and getting weaker for a variety of
reasons and that's true systemically not
only in the US and that that's going to
inevitably increase inflationary
pressure now we've seen a fair bit of
that in the last two years let's say and
it's certainly I think evident to anyone
who's thinking that the actual inflation
rate is much higher than the pronounced
inflation rate okay so now
hypothetically people are going to want
to know how to protect themselves
against inflation if they're trying to
store wealth in the long run
um trying to maintain their savings at
minimum let's say and you make a strong
case that gold is the proper medium in
which to invest savings that you wish to
maintain now you broker gold purchasing
Services we can walk through that a
little bit and so someone could say well
you know you have an iron in the fire
you have a stake and the outcome here
it's not surprising that you're putting
forward the pro gold Vision but I
presume the reason you're doing that is
because you actually believe it and are
invested that way yourself so what would
you recommend to people who are
listening and these would be people of a
moderate income let's say or perhaps on
the Lower Side what would you recommend
to them to be doing in order to protect
themselves against the threat of
inflation as the future rules forward
yeah well first of all absolutely right
I don't I don't promote gold because I
have a bunch of gold I'm looking to
unload I mean I I went into that
business because I believe that people
need to own it I mean in fact I started
shift gold uh I had I was I owned a
broker dealer and a lot of my customers
wanted gold because I promoted gold I
talked about it but I didn't I didn't
sell it at the time I was was just you
know I was stock broker and I was
helping people with their stock
portfolios but I also recommended that
they go and buy some gold and they would
go and buy it from other companies but
what was happening is people were
getting ripped off a lot of these gold
Merchants were uh overpricing their
products they were you know pushing them
into numismatics or these Collectibles
and I didn't like what was going on and
so in order to make sure that my
customers didn't get ripped off I
started my own business to so that they
could buy gold from me and I could make
sure that they they weren't pushed into
these other products and that they
bought bullion and they they paid a low
price for it so that's how I got into
the business
um because I believed in it now I don't
look at gold though as an investment I
look at gold as money
so to the extent that you want to keep
liquidity you don't want to make an
investment right you don't want to buy
real estate you don't want to buy stocks
you don't want to buy bonds you just
want to keep some cash
that's where I see gold
as a place in the portfolio right and
not the cash that you might need I mean
at least now I mean when we're starting
to use gold back crypto then you could
keep everything in Gold but for now you
want to pay your rent your landlord
isn't taking gold yet I mean he probably
will in the future but right now he
wants you know dollars or Euros so you
got to keep some cash to pay your bills
but if you're talking about cash that
you're going to hold on to that you
might use in a few years maybe to make
an investment maybe you think real
estate's going to go down maybe you
think stocks are going to go down and so
you want to you want to have some dry
powder to buy that's where you want to
keep gold instead of currency because
currency could lose so much value that
you know stocks can go down in value but
still go up in price you know so let's
say uh stocks could go down 10 or 20
percent in terms of gold but they can go
up in terms of dollars or or or Euros so
it's better to hold your dry powder in
in honest money and especially now
because if you look around the world
interest rates in almost every country
are still below the official inflation
rates which means rates are negative and
of course the the real inflation rates
are much higher than the official rates
so you're losing a lot in cash maybe 10
20 years ago that wasn't the case you
could get an interest rate that exceeded
the rate of inflation and so you were
paid for the loss of uh purchasing power
and people would say hey you don't want
to own gold because you're giving up
that interest well now there is no
interest there's negative interest gold
actually lets you avoid that negative
interest because negative interest is a
loss that's imposed On You by holding a
currency so you avoid that loss by
owning gold so gold uh is a substitute
for money
but
you want to make investments you don't
want to just leave all your money in
gold gold is a metal it's not doing
anything it's not producing anything uh
you're gonna do better over time
investing in productive assets and
that's what I do if you can identify
them yes and if you don't overpay for
them I mean that's a mistake that a lot
of people make they look at a company
that has a good product
and they think oh it let me buy that
stock well the stock could be way
overpriced so it's not just buying a
good company it's paying the right price
and because that's what's going to
determine your long-term return if you
overpay for an asset you're probably
going to lose money eventually now you
can so how would you how do you view how
do you view let's say the relative
importance of something like a good so
there are these funds which I'll just
outline this for people who are
listening that allow you to purchase a
basket of stocks essentially
and often those stocks are weighted to
the index is used to assess stock market
performance and so you can buy uh shares
in a mutual fund in a fund let's say
that owns a basket of stocks a large
basket of stocks and so then you average
your risk across many companies and you
benefit in principle from the average
increase in productivity across that
basket of Stellar companies and so those
those index portfolios have proved to be
a pretty good alternative to actively
managed money and how do you see
investing in gold in relationship to
something like investing in an index
fund well I mean they're very different
so first of all the the idea of just
indexing and just say look I'm just
going to buy the market I'm going to buy
all these stocks
you know in certain periods of time that
could work out
right because if a lot of money is
flowing into those indexes it's going to
push up the price of the stocks that are
included in those indexes but right now
because so many people have indexed
the stocks in those indexes by and large
are overpriced and if you you buy if you
overpay for an asset as I said you're
going to lose eventually now you can
overpay for an asset and you can make
money if you can sell it to somebody who
overpays by an even greater amount and
so you could trade overpriced assets if
you're Nimble and make money but if
you're a long-term investor
the way to make money is to buy
something cheap buy it when it's
undervalued especially if it pays a good
dividend because now you can collect
your dividends while you're waiting for
the asset that you bought cheap to
become expensive and I don't like
passive investing you know what I do for
my clients and what I do personally is I
actively invest
um and over the long run
that is much better than indexing over
certain periods of time
indexing can do better and then it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
because the money gets sucked in chasing
and performance how how do you know that
you're how do you know that your active
investing is allowing you to I
accurately identify stocks that are
properly or under underpriced I mean
that's the million dollar question well
there are some basic
you know truths to assessing
value of a business right you could look
at a a business because that's what a
stock is when you're buying a stock
you're buying a piece of a business so
you look at the business and you can
look at the the revenues the profits the
debt you know you could look at all
these metrics and you can tell
you know is it cheap am I buying the
income potential of this business am I
getting a good price you can look at
ratios historically that show you that
something is cheap or expensive now the
problem that a lot of people have is
their time Horizons are so short because
yes an asset can stay cheap for a while
before the price goes up and usually
when you get something cheap
it's because there's a problem
something's got to be going wrong that's
causing people to sell so what you have
to be able to do is do your homework and
decide
is this problem that is hurting the
price of this stock is it fixable is it
long term can we see beyond this problem
to the solution and is the market
getting something wrong and I'm getting
a good price conversely
when stocks are expensive it's because
they're doing great and everybody loves
them and then what you have to decide is
well are people being too optimistic
about this company that's doing really
well are there problems that the market
is not paying attention to that are
likely to come up in several years so
there are ways to do this and if you're
smart and you st you have basic
principles over the long run I think
you're going to outperform just a static
basket of stocks where you're just going
to pay whatever price the market is
demanding I mean people say well you're
saying that's partly because these index
stocks they also tend to be somewhat
inflated in value because so many people
have dumped money into them exactly
that's artificially inflating the price
of the entire basket right right because
then that counter purposes to the idea
of random sampling it's no longer random
if you're buying a preferentially priced
basket and then it's going to work in
Reverse when a lot of people want to get
out of the indexes all these stocks are
going to get sold because a lot of these
stocks don't even pay dividends I mean
the problem is let's say you're buying a
bunch of stocks they don't pay dividends
if you retire and you have all these
stocks and now you need money to pay
your bills because you don't have a job
you got to start selling your stocks and
that puts downward pressure so by by
placing those stocks in an index they're
no longer independent either right you
bundle them together and so the
presumption of Independence that was
there to begin with is violated by the
bundling of the stocks in the index but
the other point I'm trying to make is if
I'm building a portfolio for my clients
of companies that I'm buying cheap and
because I'm buying them cheap I'm
getting a high dividend I'm getting a
lot of income on my stock because see if
you're just buying a stock because you
think the price is going to go up that's
just speculating you could be wrong the
price could go down I'm buying stocks
that even if the price never goes up
I still make a good return because I'm
getting a dividend right now regardless
of what happens to the stock price so if
you build a big portfolio of good
dividend-paying stocks while you're
still working and you don't need the
income you can take those dividends and
buy more stocks and build up your
portfolio but then when you retire you
don't have to sell your stocks you just
take your checks your dividends and you
start spending those you stop
reinvesting and so that's not a Ponzi
mentality that's legitimate investing in
the market uh by buying companies that
throw the most important thing though
that I think people can do now is
recognize though if I'm right about
what's going to happen to the dollar and
the US economy the companies I'm buying
are international and their customers
are outside the United States and these
are the customers that are going to
benefit when the dollar declines and the
U.S loses that Reserve status and
Americans can no longer live above above
their means that means a lot of other
people who are living beneath their
means they're going to get a reward from
the dollars a loss of status and those
consumers in those other countries are
now going to be in better shape I want
to own businesses that have those
customers I want businesses whose
customers are going to get richer not
whose customers are going to get poor
and I want customers who have a lot of
savings not a lot of debt so I own
businesses that are going to be able to
thrive in an econ you know where the US
economy is in a lot of trouble where
it's in stagflation and I also own
companies
that sell products and provide services
that people need and they're going to
continue to buy those goods and services
even if they have to cut back on other
things to afford it you don't want to
have a portfolio where consumers can
easily do without what you're selling or
if you're not even selling anything a
lot of these tech companies you know all
their income is from advertising they
give away the products and they and they
have advertisers but if the consumers
can't afford to buy products that the
advertisers are advertising then all
that ad Revenue goes away and a lot of
these uh tech companies that have these
really high multiples you know they're
going to come crashing down okay so if
you were we're starting to come to near
the end of the time for our discussion
if you were
giving people advice who are beginning
to invest let's say these are people who
might say have a hundred to five
thousand dollars a month to invest
what would you recommend
when do you think people should start
doing that when should at what level of
income should you start to consider
putting away some of your money how much
should you put away and then what
concrete steps could you take to start
doing this it's broken down in a very
simple manner because lots of people
have no idea how to start doing this
when it comes to investing I mean the
earlier you start the better because you
get the compounding effects of that uh
now if you allow inflation to destroy
the value of what you've invested then
you know that's no good but
if somebody only has you know 500 a
thousand dollars a month to invest I
mean what I would recommend is that they
use my mutual funds I mean you could go
to uh my my uh website europac.com now I
think the minimum is twenty five hundred
dollars to get your account going right
so you have to have at least that amount
that's not a lot but you can go on my
website and just buy my funds now my
funds are also available at all the
discount brokers so if you have an
account at Schwab or Fidelity or
Ameritrade or yeah all these you know my
funds are on their platforms
but
um but then the I think the the
incremental investment you can invest a
hundred dollars or 500 at a time you
know you can you can have small
Investments once you've established uh
the portfolio but then you do get the
benefit of professional management and
diversification you get a a big
portfolio of stocks that are actively
managed by by me and my team where we
are you know looking for good
opportunities buying stocks when they're
cheap selling them if they get too
expensive
um you know constantly you know you know
evaluating our Holdings making sure that
the stocks that we thought were cheap
um because they had a problem that those
problems are being solved and that we're
right on our research and if something
comes up and we think we've made a
mistake we can sell a stock and and
redeploy the money or if we find an
opportunity that we like better than one
that we have we can you know we can make
the changes that's something that you
can't do when you're just in a in a in a
static model you know and and that's why
my my funds the performance has been so
fantastic recently uh in the last you
know one three and five years relative
our to our peers is because we've done
such a good job of
um stock picking and sector allocation I
mean not only are we way ahead of our
benchmarks which would be an index but
we're way ahead of everybody else who's
trying to beat the indexes uh but I
think the the time period where my funds
are going to do the best and I have a
value fund a dividend payer fund an
emerging market fund a gold fund and an
international bond fund it's going to be
in the future years when the dollar is
really weakening I mean the dollar
hasn't weakened dramatically yet I mean
in terms of purchasing power it has I
mean that's clear I mean you need more
dollars to buy everything but in terms
of Euros or Yen or pounds that's not the
case but that's coming I think we're
going to see a substantial decline in
the dollar relative these other
currencies and that is the environment
where my funds are going to do the best
and as inflation rates pick up and we
see a bigger increases in commodity
prices
uh that's going to really benefit my
investment strategy
so okay so let's let's close with this
perhaps so the devil to some degree is
always in time frame you know and you've
made a case for the inevitable weakening
of the American dollar as a reserve
currency and of its value as a fiat
currency and that's in keeping the
latter part in particular in keeping
with its gradual dissent into
comparative lack of value against gold
since 1971. but so
the devil is always timing and so
over what period of time do you think
this unfolding into a more inflationary
period is going to occur and and what
makes you reasonably convinced let's say
of your timing
well timing is is always difficult I um
I mean I know what's going to happen
I've known what's going to happen for a
long time right that that might be the
problem but
where we are right now is exactly where
I've been forecasting we would be even
going back to you know my predictions of
the 2008 financial crisis you know I
knew that crisis was coming because I
understood the mistakes that the Federal
Reserve made to create that housing
bubble and I knew the consequences for
the financial set system when it popped
but even before the bubble popped I knew
the mistakes the government was going to
make I I predicted QE before I even knew
the word I knew they would do this and I
knew they would inflate an even bigger
bubble uh that has finally popped
because I knew that eventually the FED
would be in a position at other central
banks where the they would have created
so much inflation that they would now be
under pressure to do something about the
inflation problem but they couldn't do
that without creating a worse financial
crisis than the one that they used
inflation to mitigate in 2008 and that
financial crisis has already started we
saw that with the failure of Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank and a lot
more Banks would have already failed had
they not been bailed out the government
Pat you know came in and propped them up
and printed more money and and came to
the rescue which is another mistake
but
we're at a point now where inflation is
going to start to run out of control
because the FED has started to return to
inflationary monetary policies
when inflation is already you know
triple it's two percent Target uh we're
starting another recession uh from the
weakest you know financial position that
we've ever been in and all the stuff
that's been happening is stuff that I
predicted in fact even when covet first
started and everybody was saying oh this
is very deflationary I said no it's not
it's massively inflationary because
we're people are not working they're not
producing and we're printing even more
money than ever we're we're we're
actually paying people more to stay home
than they earned when they actually were
productive I said this is you know
creating even more inflation and so
we're at this taking point you know and
in fact when the central banks had to
keep interest rates at zero for so long
they did that for a reason that was
because they didn't want the whole thing
imploding so they kept it on life
support until they couldn't do it
anymore because of the the outbreaks of
consumer prices but I I think we've
passed that point and and so this is
happening this is the time frame where
the air is coming out of this bubble
it's still early if you remember in 2007
when the subprime market blew up and I
was very you know active there we had
shorted a subprime market I mean you
know they they you know they made wrote
a book they made a movie about that
trade well I lived that trade we did
that trade so I I was predicting you
know subprime I mean you can go one of
my videos on YouTube is mortgage Banker
speech I gave in 2006 in front of 3 000
Mortgage Bankers I went there to promote
this hedge fund that was shorting
subprime but you could still watch my my
talk with what you don't have on the
Internet is the smaller talk that I gave
later specifically on that fund right
this was the larger talk I had about
maybe 50 people that came to the smaller
presentation about about the fun
um
but
I knew at at that time
that
the the bursting of that bubble but you
know we we would create this crisis but
when the subprime problem initially
reared its head everybody said don't
worry about it the Federal Reserve said
it was contained Ben Bernanke said don't
worry about subprime it's contained well
I was on television at that time all the
time I used to be on cable news every
week back then I said no it's not
contained this is the tip of an iceberg
this is a huge problem in the entire
mortgage Market we're headed for a
financial crisis you know it's anything
but contained well the government got
that wrong then when inflation really
burst out as far as high prices in 2021
what did they say oh don't worry about
it it's transitory
right well I said no it's not transitory
it's permanent it's here to stay they
were wrong again well they're ignoring
the warning signs again just like they
ignored uh the subprime problem just
like they ignored the outbreak of the
CPI they're ignoring all the early
warning signs of the of the financial
crisis that we're in now and the Great
Recession that's beginning that is much
worse than the last one and so
that the significant thing is going to
be the difference because I think this
time we're headed for a currency crisis
that's going to be the end result of
this next collapse is going to be the
end of the dollar status in a currency
crisis and so you have to have a very
different Investment Portfolio than the
one you had in the prior decade just
hiding out in tech stocks isn't going to
work those stocks are going to go down
you have to have the international value
the dividend paying the commodity
exposure old-fashioned type investing
gold and and that's what I'm doing and
again for for wealthier people you don't
necessarily have to buy my funds you can
buy my funds but we have separately
managed accounts so if you contact your
Pacific Asset Management we manage
portfolios individual portfolios of
stocks uh that I think will perform
extremely well during the economic
environment that we're in and that we're
going to continue to be in most people
unfortunately are going to get wiped out
people are going to lose lot in this
environment but there's going to be a
small percentage of people there always
are who will make money during this time
period And I I just prefer to be among
those people right just like you know
not everybody made money off the
subprime collapse there were a a number
of people who understood the problem and
bet against the conventional wisdom and
and and they made money and the
conventional wisdom is generally wrong
and it's wrong right now they expect
things to happen and aren't going to
happen they have a lot of confidence and
faith in central banks and the fed and
and they're wrong this is not going to
end the way they believe there is a huge
mispricing of Assets Now just like there
was for mortgages back then a lot of
people don't understand this and they're
going to suffer but the people who
understand it are going to are going to
profit and and I'm hoping that as many
people as possible I can help them
profit by by getting them properly
positioned with their portfolios
all right well that's an excellent place
to stop I would say we're pretty much
right on time there and so for everybody
who's watching and listening thank you
very much for your time and attention
and Peter Schiff thank you very much for
talking to me today and walking me
through a lot of this somewhat
Elementary material but it's very good
for people to hear exactly how these
things work right because we're not well
taught on the financial front and many
of the terms that are bandied about
inflation debt deficit investment for
that matter gold standard Fiat people
don't understand these things and to be
to provide people with that information
is extremely helpful we will link to all
of the
um opportunities that Peter described in
the description of the video so you can
check that out if you want and I'm going
to switch over to the Daily wire plus
side now and talk to Peter for another
half an hour I do that with all my
guests to get a little bit more
biographical information to find out how
we got where he is and uh maybe to delve
a bit more deeply into his ability to
have prognosticated accurately regarding
the
2008 financial crisis which was quite
the interesting catastrophe in which he
seemed to get right when very few people
did so for all of you who are watching
and listening
um maybe you can direct your interest to
the Daily wire plus side and offer them
some support in doing so they make these
podcasts for example possible and at
least at the Quality that they're now
being broadcast and Peter thank you very
much for agreeing to talk to me today
and for sharing what you know with
everybody who's listening and uh will
well we'll talk again right away and
hopefully we'll have a chance to meet at
some point in the future Jordan has been
my pleasure to be here I really
appreciate the opportunity to speak with
your audience and hopefully I can come
back and we can expand on these
principles and uh yeah if you're ever
out here in Puerto Rico
or Connecticut I'm there once in a while
but happy to happy to meet you
yeah well hopefully that'll happen in
the not too distant future and once
again oh and to everybody here I'm in uh
I'm in Monastery at the moment heligan
Croy is just outside of Vienna taping
this podcast and to the crew here thank
you very much for your help to the Daily
wire plus people for setting this up
that's always much appreciated and Peter
thanks again everyone watching ciao you
thanks for participating and we'll see
you on the next podcast
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com